thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
yo yo we out here
welcome to hot breath live everyone
how y'all doing out there
good to see y'all happy Tuesday
a co-host Yoshi is about to be here
Heather parody made it yeehaw
[Applause]
K I literally just listened to our
episode last night when I was out at
shows it's so good oh my gosh and how
much extra work you do to weave in the
commentary throughout it was very cool
all right so he's here ladies and
gentlemen
my co-host Yoshi so
yay what's happening yeah what's
happening I can see the reflection of my
screen if somebody took a screenshot
they'd see all our stuff that's so yeah
we uh we wore sunglasses today because
the future of this show is so bright
that we just had
to harness it in
had to represent
Allen Harbor just said what's up on our
um
Facebook group so we are live streaming
to our Facebook group and our YouTube
channel for those of you listening to
the podcast we are doing a live q a this
is our weekly live stream on our hot
breath YouTube channel
that you can subscribe to Linked In the
description of this episode but I want
to start this off Yoshi I went I went
back to the mud last night fam okay I
went back to that nitty-gritty open mic
just open mikeness you know like I
hadn't had I hadn't been that open Mikey
in a while but
yeah I did um I did a show in the corner
of an Irish bar on a Monday that started
at 11. the show started at 11. the show
started at 11 at 11.
that's a good one right there that's
that's how you know they serious about
comedy at like 11 o'clock that's when
comedy should be
on a Monday do you know the the critters
out and about on a Monday on President's
Day at 11 in an Irish Pub
it was a crew there was a crew dude
and the host I don't think he'd ever
hosted before Oh even better basically
started
he started the show as like hey ufs
ready for some comedy he goes hey uf's
at the bar ready for comedy like these
people are just drinking on a Monday
night and then some insane person just
stands up in the corner and swears at
them
not humorously he dropped the r word
like three times like very open Mikey
but
I just I I said all that to say I hadn't
done a show like this in a while yeah
and I hadn't had a set like I had in a
while where it was just a mental
breakdown
um I was rubbing the walls
we brought it back fam we brought it
back
[Laughter]
pause
oh yeah dude it was rock bottom but it
was and it was cool because like the um
the guy who runs at JB super cool guy so
he gave me like extra time so he was
like you could do 15 so like I stretched
it like I was stretching it out
just a good mental breakdown in front of
Seven comics and four drunk people to
really get you back in the game you know
hey that's the best that's how you
that's how you know you in it
yeah it felt very cathartic I hadn't
done anything like that in a while you
know I've been very buttoned up and like
here we are you know you and I were
starting to do a lot of country clubs
like we're getting we're getting
professional so it was good to just yeah
be in a bar on a Monday just melting
down
oh yeah yeah I I feel like you need one
of those just to reset your expectations
of what life comedy should be just to
kind of like take you out of your your
your Zone just for a little bit because
it does it's a nice little reset I'll
say what I don't like is when there's
like two or three of those resets like
in a row I don't like that I don't like
that feeling at all
that's not fun when it becomes a habit
yeah yeah when you're like okay this is
not fun yeah yeah for sure
yeah part of it though
that's that you're right this is part of
it there's a good uh there's a good spot
out in Alpharetta if you ever want to do
a Monday night that isn't as grimy as
this is it the Indian Place yeah it's I
almost drove up there last night but
Alpharetta was a minute away yeah that's
the minute that's a minute for sure
but it's a good always have a grind you
know I'm I'm a Savage with it see people
people see me now and they're like oh he
looks like a youth pastor come on down
Joel you know but like
we we started from the bottom now we're
here like the shows I've done bro you
know
grimy strip clubs and public buses and
sidewalks
and fetish conventions and like I mean
you know
kids today you know as they're doing
their open mics filming them for crowd
work clips
back in my day I was working for him
I walked to the mic both Hills
back in my day we stayed for the whole
show
we stayed for the whole show fam you
show respect to that host and those
other comics and you hang out now
everybody gotta get I got knocked out
I'm grinding Fam I'm grinding I'm gonna
go sit at this other mic and hope the
booker notices me in six months
back in my day we had to tell jokes
laughs
we actually had a right right before we
went up on stage you had to write
something think about it for a whole
week put some tags on it make sure there
was a setup and a punch line
practice it and then get up on stage now
you kids just ask somebody what do they
do for a living and then post that on a
tick tock it is and the Instagram is I
so sound like a hater right now but
that's pretty much what it feels like I
ain't hating but I mean it's like I've
seen some that it's literally like the
person says something and they respond
and that's the entire clip dude and it's
like seven seconds I've seen some where
people have uh
uh audio edited the laughs in
yes yes and are straight up doing this
against a green screen as if the other
person a club
yeah there's one there's a white dude
clearly is like clearly clearly it's
just like in his room doing this with
laugh tracks but I bet he's selling
tickets he has like a lot of followers
he has a lot of followers hey I here's
the thing if the formula is working get
it how you live you know what I mean
yeah get it how you can't ain't no
there's no formula to how this how to be
successful in this game if you find a
way you found a way and if people are
giving you tickets and putting butts in
seats because there's a thing when they
come see you that's when the truth comes
out them jokes better be fire you and me
ain't no rubbing the walls when
somebody's pain to be there nodu
yeah you got to deliver
or else
the people who booked you are going to
spread the word
oh this dude is trash and they won't let
other comedy clubs know in a hot second
and the the worst part really is that
the fans will come and see you and they
won't come back and they'll be like oh
you're he's all right we'll keep them on
the internet but we wouldn't go see them
live again we got our photo that's
enough type deal yeah yeah I mean yeah
fans are savages too yeah fans are
savages too and then some fans even go
to those shows thinking it's going to be
nothing but
uh interactive like uh crowd work stuff
and it's like you know how hard it is to
do an hour of crowd work if you're not
good at it yeah
magic happen
[Laughter]
yeah it I mean that's the game now
though you know yeah there's there's
very few comedians that can really like
knock out crowd work for like a hot
second like Akash uh schultzy
um Ian bag Ian bags
yeah yeah I mean even like I I even
think like old school comedians can like
knock out crowd work but new comedians
doing crowd work for an hour
that's not easy I mean even like
somebody like a Sam Morrell who is just
a phenomenal writer he doesn't do crowd
work for an hour he's got jokes he won't
do crowd working once in a while but
you're not seeing him to go see an hour
worth of crowd work
yeah I think his um
you know and I do as we're talking about
young Comics here as we get into our q a
there's something that came up last
night that as I was out at Open Mic I I
was in the environment and I like so I
was starting to observe some
commonalities it seems like seems like a
lot of cats are taking notes on stage I
don't know if that's a News school thing
that these kids are just like whatever
but it seemed like everyone had like
notes or a phone and were like blatantly
just going back and forth to it like and
an open mic where you're supposed to
just be
breathing figuring out how to breathe up
there and they're like well let me go
back to my notes you know what I mean
like for sure notice that I went to two
shows last night I noticed that at both
seemed like people were doing a lot of
notes is that like a new thing you kids
are doing or back in my day we buy you
with dignity
are you not a notes guy at an open mic I
will take I'm not all the time but I've
I'll take notes up there
I thought I recognized you from last
night I thought you were one of those
[Laughter]
he was in Disguise he didn't have his
sunglasses on but listen I'm I'm I'm
never someone who tells you should or
shouldn't do I only tell my experience
of course for sure so listen I don't
like notes up there
yeah you are the Carmichael shot a
special at The Comedy Store with notes
on it there's there's literally there's
dude there's no right or wrong way it's
your way do whatever do you boo but
I just feel like an open mic when you're
so young in the game I understand
someone like a Chris Rock having like
pieces he wants to get to and he's
working on stage but a young comic
you're just trying to figure out how to
be comfortable up there for sure there's
a crutch it's gonna take you longer to
get comfortable because it's how you
rise to the occasion and discomfort or
fear is how you start to build that
stage presence and this going to the
phone is like a safety valve I think
it's only shootering you
yeah I I feel you on that I I would say
that I take notes not as a crutch I take
notes simply because there are things
that I am trying that like I just need
to get out but I would say the
difference is I know the whole joke it's
just a matter of the order like I don't
know the order of the joke that I am
saying when I'm at an open mic if like I
get a kind of reaction at something I'll
go to a different joke rather than the
order that I put for my set list even
that day right because I want to like
follow certain themes but I don't go to
the I don't go to my notes as a crutch
but I get it though like especially as a
starter if you're starting out in comedy
it's it can be kind of like
something that you latch onto
um but you know I get it though I mean
hell uh
uh George Wallace takes yeah
nine by 16 legal pad up there yeah but
man he's rattling these jokes off like
foreign
but you know he's also working in Vegas
and makes a whole lot more than we will
ever make in our lifetime so maybe
whatever we make hey I ain't even for
the middle here
all right I ain't in for the middle here
speak for yourself there Mr fixed
mindset but
but um
yeah it's all this is something I
noticed you know I know there's always
exceptions have I I have have I done it
before yes I can literally think of just
literally a few times because I am that
just like passionate about not having
notes but dude
you do you boo it's just something I
noticed that
New Orleans doing this and not as like
not even giving themselves the moment to
be organic on stage as soon as they like
forget something they like go to the
phone or whatever and like they just go
yeah yeah yeah kind of that I won't that
I won't do it my notes are mostly for me
to know what am I going to and then I do
the whole joke and I'm not going back to
it to be like oh I forgot the punchline
kind of thing oh absolutely not
but yeah I get that though
um I don't know I I think
yeah anything else that you notice about
new new Comics while you were up there
um OG in this game
dang fam
um I actually took
I actually took notes in my um
notebook but I'm not exactly sure where
it is
you took notes of your notes at the
because I was at the open mic last night
like taking notes like oh I want to talk
about this tomorrow oh for sure oh I got
these kids
I mean that was the big one though
people are using notes on stage
um yeah that was the big one
yeah I figured on that
you know leave them with one thing at it
leave them with one thing a week for
them to for sure
oh and then people are divided in the
comments some people take notes some
people don't
yeah it's all it's all preference
oh preference
so let's get into some of these
questions that we posted in our Facebook
group to answer
your q a questions
so the first one I'm seeing
foreign
these people wrote like paragraphs I
don't want to read all this
we want to help but come on let's be
within reason I'm just kidding
[Laughter]
oh and by the way my breakdown like
wasn't killing like it wasn't like oh
this is cool and experimental people
were just like what is happening
yeah is it because you were going long
like what do you what do you think was
the Catalyst to the breakdown or the
jokes that were just not working
will the break I listen back to it and
the breakdown started
when like a new joke I was real excited
about that just killed at the show I did
before
yeah just like fell flat and I was I
immediately just went back to like
like three-year-old Joel just all right
we're rubbing the walls we're talking to
ourselves we're getting into it
I'm gonna scare these young Comics
tonight I'm scared I'm like this is your
future
so do you think do you think the rubbing
of the wall is a crutch
oh no no no no I haven't done it in
years
how dare you even equate that to someone
not knowing their jokes and looking at
their notebook as a crutch
oh
please you just tried to like because
you use no try oh let me try to reverse
psychology my way
no no no no I I was saying it is like
what what turned you into going down the
rabbit hole of the wall rubbing I think
I'm trying to figure out like was it
that the joke wasn't working or like
because it didn't pop
what was sort of like your mental game
after that joke didn't hit like you
wanted it that's what I was trying to
get yeah yeah because I used to do that
like if my if my like opening breath
didn't get a laugh I would just bail on
the set and be like oh I guess it's
gonna be one of those huh like
immediately
so then from that like sometimes I would
turn around and just rub the wall so I
think when that joke
I was really excited about that's been
killing and doesn't at this bar at 11
o'clock on a Monday
for sure I think my brain was just like
ooh we haven't done this in a while
let's get back to the let's get back to
the foundation let's get back to the
fundamentals here
okay okay that's what I was wondering I
just did a video on Steve Martin
yeah it literally took me like 16 hours
to script and research I tracked the
time I was like there's no way but
I'm putting it at work baby but so I've
been in this weird world for a while
like researching him and just what he
did so I think yeah that may have been
part of as well but like oh let's just
break free tonight
yeah now what happens tonight I don't
know but my brain has been
um all over the place
okay
all right since I uh I drank the Super
Bowl and then I drank a Valentine's Day
my brain is just like hey remember
anxiety
remember that
remember why you quit drinking I was
just like uh so I'm still like kind of
my brain is still kind of coming out of
that fog for sure for sure
understandable
that's the worst part about therapy is
that you just know you gotta listen I
did it
look you know you have to tell them
something but it's not for like another
week and you're like fine
I do love therapy because you do have to
tell on yourself you're like how's it
going you're like uh uh I'd have messed
up yeah
you know
that thing that I said I was gonna work
on I didn't
I mean I worked but not on that I worked
on unworking that
yeah
that's funny imagine going to like a
comedy therapist being like ah damn I
started rubbing the walls this week what
do you think that means
did you diagnose that
[Laughter]
is that a mommy issue daddy issue or is
that just a joke where does that stem
from let's start to work on it
oh my God it's so true dude
so it's been weighing on me ever since I
drank I was like
to tell her
I have to tell it's all good I think I
also broke broke last night because I've
really been trying to do not do white
stuff
and then I did something white and it
like really killed and I was like [__]
it's like I'm really trying not to and I
end up just doing it more not trying to
I don't know why I do feel like that's a
crutch I feel like that's why I'm trying
not to do it because yeah because you
feel like it has become a crutch for me
yeah I can feel it okay I just don't
want that I don't want that laugh
anymore
yeah hey
understandable man but if you see me out
in these streets I may be doing them
just so you know I'm a hypocrite
um
all right so I'll pull up in our
Facebook group
so the uh the first one
we have here let's start off with a
light one Vanessa Ray asked just how
many licks does it take to get to the
Tootsie Roll
yeah
I think it's in the two to three hundred
range
um I have counted before
uh back in my day back in the day yeah I
mean do you remember Tootsie Rolls yeah
I remember the owl commercial yeah yeah
you actually did it
oh dude I mean we listen to everything
cartoons told us to do
oh Smokey the Bears that don't you know
don't light anything in the woods I was
like all right cool Smokey you seem cool
to me let's let's not do that
you know what I mean people said don't
get on drugs that that worked for a
while
um but yeah uh it's about 200 or 300 I
say 250. that's the magic number is 250
licks to get to the center of a Tootsie
Roll
there you go Vanessa Ray asking the
hard-hitting questions
boom Blau
next one up oh and Alan Harper said in
the live chat that uh food Theory did a
video on that interesting
that's funny nice
okay so so act sorry so some comedy
questions here
from Allen Harbor actually let's do his
so
he says say you don't want to or can't
do traditional stand up but want to tell
your jokes on platforms like Tick Tock
and YouTube what are some tips or
strategies
foreign
you don't want to do traditional stand
up but you want to tell jokes on YouTube
or tick tock
I think you just do it standing yeah
from your room yeah like a talking head
video and see what happens I think the
key is like there's so many ways to
Define comedy right there's so many
people who are calling themselves
comedian and
in their right they are a comedian
because they're making people laugh so
in that definition of a comedy of a
comedian if you are making people laugh
you are technically a comedian so
however you are delivering that message
or that content really is upon you
there's so many things that are working
right now so many things that are you
know that I would have never thought
would ever work on a stage but people
are doing it they're working it people's
reactions are very different these days
so yeah I think the key to this one is
just do it try it see what happens and
then try it again make it better
yeah I mean the the tip or strategy is
that you just post and try several
different things
and see what you enjoy the most and what
is working the best so it's like you may
experiment with a joke that you just
holding your phone and talking to it or
it's something you do in your car that's
a part more of like a series or you
don't do it talking to the phone you do
it as like a skit that you act out and
then you play different characters in
this skit or you have friends to do it
with you so
the Tipper strategy is like okay you
don't want to get on stage you want to
create comedy online is basically what
you're saying so yeah just start
experimenting just like with stand up
you get on stage and try things out and
what works you keep building on
same thing with social media so just
approach that stand-up mindset but just
apply it to what you create on social
media but doing it I mean honestly
starting and getting consistent is the
number one thing
action action action so like another
strategy is like all right I just want
to post something every day this week it
doesn't have to be funny it could be the
same thing I just want to hit the post
button seven days seven times this week
and just start there to build the Habit
because consistency and
what's going to be fun to you is how
you're going to build it
boom
I would drop this one but we're able to
do hot breath for over six years for
free
you're welcome
for the culture you know we just love it
we just love helping Comics just love
interviewing
comedians over 400 episodes
for free just putting in that work yeah
hey you know what or grin it down
you just grin it down but you know
that's what these young cats you know
that's
they don't see that invisible work they
don't I don't know Shawty
all right
here's a good one about getting booked
Jack Allen from across the pond
across the pond
what's the appropriate amount of time to
message a Booker again if they didn't
acknowledge or see your first message or
email I don't want to be too persistent
and annoy them but I've always but I've
also had success when messaging again
after six months
um you know I I
when I went to the World Series and met
like maybe like 15 20 Bookers
the consistent advice
was about once a month to reach out
and if you don't get a response back
keep reaching out and if you're once a
month is too many they will let you know
but keep reaching out
so I would say that's the magic number
it's about once a month mainly because
that's how often they're checking their
calendars on who to book you know some
you would think that all comedy Bookers
look like
a couple months out but some people book
like a couple weeks out some people will
book a couple of days out every Booker
is so different because every Comedy
Club has different needs and different
desires
um so I would say probably once a month
is kind of the magic number
for Bookers that I saw consistently
through you know the 1520 comedy Bookers
who probably
manage about
40 to 50 percent of the comedy clubs in
America because the guys from The Comedy
Zone were there House of Comedy like the
people that have like franchises across
the country they were all there they're
like yeah about once a month is sort of
that magic number
yep exactamundo
next question El proximo pregunta
is the
uh
uh Jerry Kroll
it's a given that you need great
material and performance to get booked
networking
has to be as important for booking and
progressing what are some of your
networking stories
that surprised you with how it brought
you up a level example
met a comic Booker producer on a flight
or in a McDonald's staying after shows
to talk with other comedians for 30
minutes
yeah or had a recommendation come from
someone you hardly knew
do you want to go first on this one
networking God it's quite a mouthful
there
um there's a lot of writing so we'll
have to edit that for next time
let's it's kind of like the joke economy
it's like word economy for the jokes for
feedback it's like God you really gotta
tighten these
what's the premise what's the premise
and let's work from that
it's funny it's the same thing
they're on Facebook so there's no
character limit
[Laughter]
be getting it in
that's so funny okay so let me go back
networking
I mean gosh I mean
I mean the one that comes to mind
and I will say like all the people I've
interviewed like
most people's like have said that like
all your opportunities are going to come
from your peers so it's like it's not
some manager agent that's gonna hook you
up it's always going to be a friend
you've known
since way back when who now is the head
writer of a TV show and they need more
writers or actors or things like that
like
it's always it's always going to be your
network so just keep that in mind
and it's something I didn't take
seriously early on I was very aloof and
I just went from show to show
didn't really Network didn't really hang
out and as a result didn't really get on
the cool shows hence the strip club show
we talked about earlier
um
but one that did
I guess that really
took me a lot farther than I expected
was probably Miss Pat
when I started the podcast and I wanted
to interview the 10 Atlanta 10 comedians
from Atlanta on Last Comic Standing
and I was like I didn't even know her or
anything
but got referred by a friend
in the network she did the podcast we
hit it off
and she took me
a few years later she took me to JFL
with her
and got to do all the just VI backstage
VIP like
I'm in The Green Room of Rose battle
because that's what Miss Pat was doing
and like it was like Judd Apatow and
John Mulaney like two feet away and
you're just like
but I think what that moment taught me
is it's like oh everybody's just people
like I wasn't in there just like oh [__]
like it's more like oh we're all like
we're all like silly gooses in here so
that's probably one that like I didn't
expect Beyond just getting to interview
her after getting referred to her to
then like to build a relationship like
that so you just never know
that's legit dude I don't know if I can
top that I mean mine is probably a bit
uh like so I I will say I like
networking that's probably like one of
my superpowers honestly for sure yeah
yeah it is that I don't mind hanging
after a show just so like I'm I'm a
people person I'm an extrovert unlike
many comedians as I'm finding out I like
the energies of people so I'm okay
hanging out for a hot minute my wife
will always say you're always the last
one to leave and I'm okay with that I'm
completely okay being like the last one
because I didn't want to miss out on
anything because if we're hanging out
we're gonna hang out kind of thing so uh
I'm trying to think what story like you
know I'd probably say one of the
best ones is like
seeing
someone in one city and then them
hooking you up in another city was very
yeah
right so I'm not I'm trying to remember
who it was so I can name Drop Like Joel
did over there
um but you're great you are great at
networking that's something that you and
I have talked about before that you're
good about hanging out and I and I've
tried to learn that from you
I was at a show in Atlanta and a
comedian and here here's the thing I'll
I'll I'm also terrible about following
up but here's how I will drop a name and
then let you know how bad I didn't
follow up uh on it but they were like
hey
um but Steve Byrne I met Steve Byrne in
Nashville Stephen just got a new Prime
is it is it on Amazon Prime it is on
Prime yeah yeah yeah just got a new
special and I met Steve Byrne in
Nashville I think he saw me do a show
and he was like Hey man if you're ever
in Atlanta hit me up and uh I'll put you
on the show and then I was doing my
normal networking thing which is I like
to go the punchline every once in a
while and Steve Byrne was literally
there and he was like man why don't you
hit me up I would have put you up on the
show and I was like
hot damn
now you're now you're cool
but now I'm cool with them and honestly
I'm sure that if he was ever in the city
and I'm like hey Steve what's up he
would be like yeah yeah come to the show
I'll get you on kind of thing but yeah
that's the power of it but also it's
like
he saw a little bit of my comedy he was
actually talking in the background but I
think what connected him is that we hung
out and uh funny enough we neither of us
drank and so but we were around a whole
bunch of people that were drinking and
we were just talking the entire night
just about comedy and how he got started
he told me about his uh
yeah like he did
yeah I don't think he was drinking wow
at least at the time at the time uh he
wasn't drinking and
um he was telling me about like the Rick
he did the uh like that 23 hours worth
of what's that thing that he did in New
York where he did like 23 sets or 20
something sets like 14 shows in a night
he's like 13 or die or something yeah I
watched that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah of
just like he was just back to back doing
shows show after show up the show and we
just got into the details of that and
like I was it was like super fascinating
but yeah it was awesome
oh
all right
[Laughter]
did I bore you with my networking
stories
Joe's like you're really good at
networking but I don't want to hear
about it
no I like
before this I had pancakes
because
um lint
starts tomorrow and today
the tradition is it's you uh you have
pancakes it's called Like Fat Tuesday is
what it's called and um so you have
pancakes on Fat Tuesday yeah before
before lent when you repent
um for all of yours but basically I had
pancakes before this and it's just
starting to hit me it's like oh yeah
um
but your your story was great and Steve
is a super nice guy and uh he kills
and I did interview him I haven't
released it yet
and um he did give me a guest spot
and I killed that [__]
[Laughter]
just in case y'all were wondering there
was no rubbing of the walls it was just
it's the mattering of the crowd
yeah no no wall rubbing on this one no
no no we stayed in the pocket
we stayed in the pocket but it was one
of those things of like oh maybe he'll
see me and be like you're the future but
it's like it's just another set you know
what I mean like at the end of the day
like we can build up everything oh this
will be the one and this will be the one
I mean and then I mean and that's the
other thing it's like there's times when
like comedians would just be legit like
good set and sometimes they don't say
anything but it also doesn't mean that
that wasn't a good set either right like
sometimes we're always waiting for like
our peers to like recognize but it's
like hey man people have are in their
own little minds and doing other things
in their mind like don't sweat waiting
for a reaction by somebody
I didn't think that camaraderie at the
open mics Like Comics were super nice to
each other I remember
on the first mic I went to
at the Laughing Skull it was like a
first timer performer and then when she
got off everyone was like yeah nice job
welcome yeah welcome to Comedy and all
this like um there's a lot of good
positive camaraderie going on around the
scene I was very happy to see that's
awesome to hear
because that's not always been the case
you know it has not
no he has not
all right
somebody asked a question in the
comments real quick let me see how do
you calm your nerves or anxiety before
or during a set
Mr Byers how do you calm your nerves
before or during a set look at this this
is a nice tight 45 character question
was this on YouTube
um
I don't know where it's from it might be
YouTube oh cool I posted in the YouTube
community and I think some questions
were posted there too
yeah oh yeah these Facebook ones are
very long-winded so
what was it um
what was the question it was about
calming your nerves before a set
yeah before or during a set
uh something that helps me and actually
just talked about this on a Heather
parody's podcast which is available now
uh she may still be watching she was
here at the beginning but I always set
like an intention
for my set name made your name drop and
always write like breathe smile slow
down like I write these things on my set
list
so I kind of enter the set with that
intention and that kind of focusing on
those instead of like what could go
wrong or what if this joke doesn't work
or how am I gonna like I gotta remember
everything instead of focusing on all
that just focusing on these simple
things smile
breathe slow down have fun
having those really keep me grounded and
calm for a set
yeah
um I would say it took me a while to
start doing this but I kind of do very
something very similar and it's I tell
myself I'm still amazing even if this
goes bad
yeah yeah
just right before I go up
I'm still awesome even if this goes bad
and it calms me down and I think part of
it is I used to be a DJ and I always
remember like if I prepare for the first
thing I'm gonna say or the first song
that I'm gonna do everything else is
easy then I'm just in the pocket but
it's that first thing and sort of just
getting the first thing out and that's
the thing that I actually get nervous
about even my kids today I always ask
are you always are you nervous I'm like
always nervous
but I know my cycle and I know like what
happens to my body when I am nervous and
I am in tune with it to know just got to
get the first thing out once the first
thing is out then my body kind of comes
into itself and then I perform but it's
usually just that first thing but yeah I
usually tell myself hey
no matter what I'm still awesome and
then I go up
breathing like taking
yeah deep breaths can help I'm just
absolutely slowing down and during the
set I always say uh if you're anxious
during like if something you know I'd
say a rub on a wall if you're nervous
um during the set
or or just like honestly I I would say
just like take a beat like it's okay to
be silent for just a little bit and then
reset yourself even if you're on stage
there's nothing wrong I know some Comics
I remember this is one of the things I
appreciate about Rob Hayes
um is
he just takes a beat between every
single joke
like he doesn't rush it and I love it
because it feels like he's just
resetting himself
it's almost like oh got it he unplugs
and then plugs back in and I loved
watching that and watching him
especially in the city I'm like this
guy's not I I couldn't tell whether it
was nerves or it was just his routine
but I liked seeing it because it just
felt like he was comfortable regardless
of the silence yeah very authentic
very often yeah I hope that helps there
I'm not sure who asked that
um
oh oh okay oh I see it on YouTube now
yeah yeah
um Daniel Hobbs asked as a new comic how
do you handle the Heckler
that just doesn't shut up
I think someone posted about this in our
Facebook group as well they got all it
was a Hot Topic in our Facebook group I
think I got a lot of uh comments going
um
yeah but I mean for me
should I start this yeah go ahead I
don't I don't want to be another Miss
Pat situation where I like say something
like well golly gee
um
yeah I'm just waiting for the name drop
real quick but go ahead yeah of a
Heckler so I was heckling Sam Kinison
yeah no no no no no no
I mean Heckler is like
gosh there it's so tricky because
well one thing to remember with the
Heckler is like that the audience is on
your side
so it's like they want him or her to
shut up as much as you do so yeah
approaching it as like a conversation
where it's you in the audience speaking
to this person instead of you
talking at this person that's like and
thinking you can like Fight Fire With
Fire
yeah most of the time you can just let a
Heckler fall on their face and it's also
important to know what kind of heckle it
is sometimes someone is trying to
disturb the show other times they're
just drunk and just talking along with
you or another time they're just super
excited and just say like say things out
loud not realizing yeah that they're
like disrupting the show yeah to
identify what kind of heckle it is and
that can help kind of determine how you
approach it
but I will also say
um
that also ignoring the Heckler
a lot of times they may stop
not all the time but if you just don't
address it they may realize oh maybe I
shouldn't do that and they'll stop
but if they don't then you can kind of
assess all right what's Happening Here
try to yes that's it that way there's
scales to heckling right like a small
scale is like you say it a joke and then
the Heckler may say something like man
that's crazy I just did that last week
that's a fun Heckle you mean like you
just recognized that you said a joke
he's like uh he she or whatever they're
like oh I identify with that joke kind
of thing now you've got something to
kind of go on I always say treat
hecklers in positive light
don't mean the Heckler because demeaning
the Heckler makes you look bad for
putting down the Heckler if you spin it
into a positive you can usually win that
entire battle
then the other level is when an Heckler
like you said is trying to disturb the
show or they're drunk or they just don't
know what they're doing one of the
things I recognize and I think we talk
about this is that when people are going
to comedy shows
a lot of people actually haven't been to
the comedy show before
it's like the first look at maybe third
time ever going to a comedy show and
that's most people that I see at the
comedy club it's not like there's not a
huge amount of people that are
consistently going to comedy shows so
people actually aren't trained to know
what to do so they're just going to go
to it instinctual like oh I may have
seen this I think it's okay to heckle
just because and then sometimes you just
gotta be like you know I prefer if you
laugh that'd be better you know I'm
saying like I have some comebacks for
hecklers that are much more positive
than like just demeaning the person and
uh and if you're like one of those
comedians who are like uh like an Ian
bag they'll just start asking the
Heckler questions and then make it part
of the material which is also I think a
good way to positively spin it you know
I mean like if the heck was like talking
it's okay to engage them and then see if
you can get material out of it but get
to the material very very fast so
they're not the center of attention any
longer yeah you don't want them to
become a part of the show you really
kind of want to hit it and quit it as
they say
pause
um so we're approaching the end of the
hour here but
uh let's do one more from this is Riley
Galvin in our uh YouTube Community post
I posted
posted there and in our Facebook group
getting Gathering people's questions we
appreciate everyone that posted them
and we do this every week so please
subscribe to the YouTube channel hit the
Bell so you get notified when we do go
live so you don't miss out
on DS comedy gold
comedy gold
so the final question here is from Riley
Galvin
when should you move to a bigger
stand-up scene New York La
Etc
[Music]
um
it's really a personal preference
it's really what you want out of it I
mean I know people who move
to La two years into their comedy career
and ended up on Conan the next year and
then
I know other people from that never left
Atlanta and have been able to build
careers and even smaller scenes where
there may not be as many shows or
opportunities
still in those scenes you can kind of
create your own shows your own events
look for surrounding cities and see
where else you could do shows and maybe
start your own and get paid to be a
comedian which is always nice
but you don't unless you just want to
move
you don't really have to like now with
technology
you really kind of build a career from
anywhere essentially but if you want to
move to New York or LA
then it's kind of on your own time I
think
one I asked Jared Harris one time when I
was thinking about moving to LA
and he's like you want to treat it like
college that it's like you be in your
home scene for four years
that's like high school and then if you
want to graduate to like a bigger Pond
then that's when you would move that was
kind of his advice when I was thinking
about it but I ended up not moving
because I just
ended up not being about that life I
knew friends that had moved and them
sleeping on couches and
like four Dudes in a two-bedroom
apartment in New York I was like
[Music]
so uh but that's a personal preference
that was me so I wanted to build it all
from Atlanta
so it's just kind of
personal preference on that of when to
move or not I think
yeah no that's that's pretty solid
advice I mean I I would say it is
personal preference and it just depends
on your lifestyle man like this is your
lifestyle
give you the ability to be able to move
I mean uh uh buddy of mine Hans Kim he
just traveled and had a he just he had
like a sprinter van
and just moved into different scenes
like but he lived out of his Sprinter
van yeah he's on kill Tony now but he
lived out of a sprinter van and just
moved like he went to New York he came
to Atlanta for a little bit I think he
might have did in Denver and he just you
know this is what he wanted to pursue
but also doesn't have like children or
like uh a wife like he's doing stuff
because he's able to kind of like do
that and make those decisions because
he's not responsible for anybody at the
moment right and so I think it's about
sort of like what do you want to do with
your comedy career I mean and then you
got to get look at people like uh who
just came back
um
uh who just came back from New York
in Atlanta
yeah
Andrew George
no well Andrew Trace has come back but
[Music]
um
Eddie Andy Andy Samford
oh right yeah yeah we went to New York
for like 10 years or so and then just
moved back right and I think sometimes
people think the move and I remember
talking to Andy I think the move is like
going to change their career trajectory
the reality is you gotta grind just as
hard as you were in your home City and
now you're just a smaller fish and a
bigger Pond right and you still got to
break through
all the noise as before but with
technology these days you can be
discovered in any City there's not like
comedians there's not like this just
this influx of comics getting found only
in New York and only in La just so you
know like and like there's a lot of
cities I would say that are really solid
comedy cities if you're thinking about
going to maybe not at La or maybe not a
New York Austin Denver
Atlanta Atlanta people out here in
Nashville people are here are grinding
and they're getting gigs right and so
I think to your point again personal
preference I wouldn't
I wouldn't move
just for the sake of moving unless you
just really just want to move
yeah if you want to go for it
yeah yeah
no pressure on that pressure
well there we go
that's it you did it we did it
hot press live in the books again we do
this every Tuesday
so if you're listening to the podcast
go subscribe to our YouTube channel hit
that notification Bell and join our
email list we're gonna be doing some
cool things on the email list
go ahead and join that
and get in on those goodies but we made
it
we made it almost fell asleep at one
point but the eye is kicked in dude I
hadn't had pancakes in years
oh really
I remember last time I had pancakes but
I'm feeling them
as I'm grabbing my stomach right now I'm
feeling them yeah I'm feeling them yeah
[Laughter]
very nice
the plan was playing
this subscribe to our YouTube channel go
join the email list and we'll be back
next Tuesday at 5 PM eastern time we
will be back
boo Yao boom bow plow bye y'all
bow